Kim Kardashian confirms she's expecting
a third child with Kanye West I'm so
excited about it after lots of
speculation that the reality star and
her rapper hubby are expecting a third
child via surrogate we haven't confirmed
anything
Kim is finally confirming the baby news
herself in a new promo for season 13 of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians the mom
of two spills the beans while on the
phone with her sister Khloe what happens
every time I say guess what the clip
also shows Coco's relationship with the
soon-to-be father of her first child
Tristan Thompson let's cue Takeo music
while Kourtney weighs in on her
relationship with Scott Disick I've
given up on being with the person that I
have to reach into it and reveals she
has a new man she's a boyfriend now yeah
the mom of three is seemingly referring
to 24 year old Eunice Benjamin the two
first sparked dating rumors in May and
on Wednesday the lovebirds pact on the
PDA sharing a steamy kiss at a Paris
soccer game
[Music]